right welcome ladies and gentlemen to
the College readout which today will be
presented to you by Commissioner Schmitt
whom we are happy to have with us today
it will be followed immediately by the
Commissioner statement on the
communication on a strong soul for
Europe for just transition and I would
just like you to remind you that at five
o'clock we will have a second conference
on the Green Deal investment plan just
transition mechanism just transition
from Commissioner the floor is yours for
the college wheeler thank you very much
good afternoon so first my college
readout and then we can have an exchange
on on the social roadmap and the minimum
wage proposal the college today
appointed in the UN song as the new
Secretary General of the Commission and
this decision takes immediate effects so
important information second the college
decided to authorize the legal service
to ask for interim measures to the
European Court of Justice related to the
infringement procedure initiated by the
European Commission on the issue of the
disciplinary regime for Polish judges
thirdly the college adopted a
communication on the strong social
Europe for just transitions and a
consultation document on the first phase
of a consultation of social partners
under Article 154 of the treaty on the
functioning of the European Union and I
will be happy to present this in more
detail and answer your questions in a
moment
firstly the Commission adopted the
communication on the European Green Deal
investment plan that sets out the
strategy to unlock 1 trillion of
investment in order to reach the
ambitious objectives of the European
Green Deal it also approved the proposal
for regulation establishing a just
transition fund that as part of a
broader just transition mechanism will
assist the region's facing the biggest
difficulties to adapt to the challenges
of climate change as part of this
overall investment strategy both of
these elements as mr. Mama's already
said will be presented to you in more
detail by commissioners gentiloni Han
and Ferrara around five o'clock the High
Representative presented the latest
developments in the area of external
relations with a focus on the
announcement by III countries meaning
France Germany and UK to trigger the
dispute resolution mechanism on the
implementation of the GC POA way so the
nuclear agreement with Iran on the Iraq
Libya and the Sahel reach so that's for
the college without